oh hi everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where today i have this
box to unbox um first
up even though this is a weird way to do
an intro because i am half box
that is what she said uh my hands are
wrapped
but to be clear i'm doing okay
they're just a little bit sore at the
bottom and i wanted to add the padding
today because i've been moving a bunch
of stuff just to kind of give me more
cushion
so that things don't hurt as much but
it's not as dramatic as it looks i
promise
this isn't a oh my gosh why are you
spending time making this youtube video
type situation
i'm doing okay so what i have here is a
box from first four figures who
um if you have known me for a while
you will know i am a huge fan first four
and prime one are my absolute favorites
also really big fan of codabakia
i mean there are a number of them but uh
i have been
unboxing first four figures for a while
on this channel as you know a
consumer as someone who was buying all
of them because i'm just such a big fan
of their work
so they reached out to me and asked if i
would want to unbox these ones these are
the legend of zelda breath of the wild
zelda and link
10 inch pvc painted statues uh master
edition
and first up this is such a nice
cardboard box
like on this side
it's really nice they they really didn't
uh
skip on anything what i really like
about them especially you know as
someone who
was a fan of first four but didn't
actually buy my first statue of theirs
until i was
21 because they're very expensive these
ones are a bit more affordable which is
cool um
they're more around the hundred dollar
mark rather than being you know yeah
400 600 type i did mention it at the end
of the video but thought i would mention
it here the legend of zelda breath of
the wild zelda and link master edition
statues are 189.90
they're coming out in quarter two of
2021 and are currently available for
pre-order okay bye
let's just move this coffee real quick
okay cool
this is beautiful look at it
it's like i don't want to throw this box
out
look how pretty it is oh my gosh
the sides are really sleek just says
legend of zelda breath of the wild zelda
and link
on the bottom let's open it
up oh this is hurting my hands a bit
it's fine i'm doing okay
we'll get there come on bud oh gosh
so weak come on come on come on you got
it yeah
yeah okay that's a lid done i think i
should move the camera down a bit let me
do that
okay on this side because mine are both
samples because they were sent
by the team rather than purchased these
authenticity cards
that first four figures have basically
you get to register your products and
they have benefits
they have a lot of really good services
um but for me these are just samples
okay then we open up there's a little
tag here
i'm very excited this is such beautiful
presentation um okay i think i probably
tip it tip it like this
and then left again [ __ ]
the thing is like my hands still hurt a
bit but it's mostly that they're really
weak
so it's just things that seem like they
shouldn't be difficult
can be disproportionately difficult it's
happening i'm doing it
okay let's go aha
okay which way is this gonna face oh
this is all so nice
my gosh that or i'm just really easily
impressed
i don't know
wow
these are really cool tada here is the
box
the back says there once was a disaster
that became known as calamity and hyrule
kingdom
collapsed this is a story of a hundred
years after calamity link is the main
character wakes up from a long sleep in
the underground ruin
then he hears a mysterious voice and
following that he steps out into the
wildland what a good
game breath of the wild is a gosh dang
good
dang video game dang i bought my sister
a switch for her birthday last year
and she started playing breath of the
wild which is
you know one of my favorite games ever i
think it's fantastic i know there are
some people who are like detractors who
are like news overrated
but i like it and she's not a huge gamer
and um getting like text updates from
someone
playing breath of the wild for the first
time and like not having any facet of it
spoiled to them because they don't pay
attention to video games is
very fun okay we have more bits to cut
back here
oh gosh okay there's totally gonna be
more than i'm gonna have to do this is
it's like i decided to do an unboxing
but like on challenge mode you know
and i just want to be clear first floor
sent me this
and did not demand that i did this ahead
of time i told them i had been in an
accident that it might take a while
just want to be clear that they were not
like hurry up alana where's the unboxing
they gave me no pressure whatsoever this
is all self-inflicted pain
they didn't even actually require an
unboxing um
it's not even a thing that i needed to
do for them you know
i just chose to okay let's go
but you out
this like backing sheet is really nice
though too
um see it's like a little diorama
sort of display with the environment
that's really nice
all righty ooh you have two little
booklets yeah it does oh there's a there
are parts to to cut the diamond
backdrops they've been doing that for a
while which um i really love
they have advertised their majora's mask
here which i have i have their darunia
that was the first statue i bought this
also includes a gift of 500 reward
points as a thank you
alrighty is there any more tape on this
it's tape free you love to see it okay
oh this is this is not hard
i can do this oh piece of candy okay
oh my gosh he's absolutely beautiful
okay we'll get to it we'll get to it
we'll get to it comes with a charger
cable because they do both
light up oh man these are awesome
yes we like them okay let me go grab my
old pvc link
who's up there somewhere for comparison
and um move the camera all right here we
have all three this is our first link
that um
first four figures released quite some
time ago and then i've just plugged
these two both in so that we can see how
they light up but
um i thought i'd give you this really
quick shot of the three of them
before we bring you in even closer so
obviously the thing that you'll notice
the first for these two guys
is that we have a bigger base on the new
link
but otherwise i will say i mean i've
only seen the back of both of them so
far i will say
very very very similar designs they are
clearly the same sort of
build everything seems to be the same
color i think
the updated link is a little bit darker
he definitely has darker eyes
you can see the faces there
you've got darker eyes
for sure but uh very similar otherwise i
realized that i am speaking to my camera
and my microphone is all the way back
here
uh yeah dynamic pose is always a thing
as a collector that's been really
important to me um
obviously paintwork is something that
that means a lot and what materials they
use but
for pvc this is kind of exactly what you
expect in terms of color
the pose is the thing that appeals to me
the most i love the action pose from
this one
now zelda i have not had my hands on
before she also looks pretty lovely to
me
uh also very dark around the eyes i love
the shading in her hair there are
definitely at least two different shades
going through here
um a darker blonde and a lighter blonde
which is really nice and she's got this
sort of
pearlescent thing going on on her
sort of ribbing in the chest if you can
see that which is actually really nice
obviously they look really cool next to
each other um but here's a part i'm
super excited about
what does it look like when we light
them up let's do it
yeah that's uh that rules
oh my gosh the uh
the arrow and then on zelda
it's on the tablet that's so neat
oh my gosh very cool
obviously the base cost is really nice
lighting on the whole thing but um
this is very awkward because
as i say every time i just do not have
the space
for an unboxing setup so
here we are you guys might have seen
zelda flicker when i had the lights out
um the reason for that is because there
are actually
three lighting settings underneath here
there's one which is this one
that makes it kind of uh glow on and off
and then there is a middle one which is
just a
constant bright light and then off of
course so
um yeah you can change those settings as
you want that's that's pretty common for
first of all figures i have the king of
red lions
up above my fridge uh statue that they
did and it's
has pretty similar stuff just adds a
little bit of atmosphere i think i tend
to like the constant ones a bit more
just so it doesn't catch my eye from a
corner of a room or something quite as
much
again that could be a problem of someone
who lives in a studio apartment i don't
know
but yes a huge thank you to first four
figures for sending me these i'm
such a big fan and also really stoked to
see them do more
affordable uh collectors items of course
again these are the 10 inch
pvc uh painted statues
part of the master line and i guess
while you're here i highly recommend
checking out uh first four figures their
facebook page their collectors club
rather it's a group gives you a lot of
details about stuff they are making so
if you do want to pre-order something
that you can
get in one of their lists but also they
actually
from from what i've seen let people have
you know some input and share their
thoughts on stuff that's uh being
prototyped are in the works as well as a
lot of cool teasers so
definitely check them out they're a
really cool group of people over there
i'm a big fan
and i think these are absolutely
beautiful so
there's that very nice work
across the board the only thing uh that
i can see is any issue with them is
it's a couple of bits where the paint's
a bit off like a couple of links arrows
at the back here are not perfectly
painted
i think there is like some kind of
scratch on the back of the shield here
and because it's pvc you can see the
occasional seam line but they've done a
really good job of hiding that
these are um in general absolutely
lovely i think that i'm gonna find
somewhere to put them that's not on the
shelf where i have most of my
collectibles because that's so hidden
i might use these like strategically as
lights somewhere because they're just
really pretty
but that is it from me today everyone
sorry for continuing to do the worst
unboxings ever
now featuring bad stupid weak hands but
i'm alana and i will see you guys next
time bye